just looking at the Twitter emails I
found that back in 2017 the Pentagon had
this network of fake identities in Yemen
in Syria in Iraq Arab language accounts
that they took covert that they removed
any kind of identification with the
Pentagon and they asked Twitter secretly
we bought this network of propaganda
accounts
uh
can you help us boost them and so you
know back in the day when you received a
verified blue check if it gave you a a
variety of benefits you couldn't be
blacklisted you were more likely to
Trend Twitter engineered a special
verification check mark for the
pentagon's Arab language propaganda
accounts but without the blue check so
it was an invisible blue check that
conferred the same benefits they later
classified this whole project but worked
with Twitter worked with Facebook and
then created fake news portals basically
to project the pentagon's message